j'en parlais en début d'émission
mobilize et 50 ans en Yvelines ont
présenté leur partenariat aux
Technocentre Renault mardi dernier une
collaboration à propos des données
relatives à l'état des routes et aux
conditions de circulation dans
l'agglomération pour parler de cette
initiative Nicolas dandry bonsoir
bonsoir alors tout d'abord qu'est-ce que
mobile eyes c'est la nouvelle marque du
groupe Renault crée suite à la
réorientation stratégique la renolution
en 2021 alors mobilez ne vend pas de
véhicule cette marque propose des
services liés à la mobilité pour
répondre notamment aux problématiques
environnementales par exemple c'est de
l'autopartage c'est la location de
véhicule de type Autolib ou encore c'est
le développement de bornes de recharge
électrique tous les services proposés
sont 100% électrique et connectés et
alors en quoi consiste ce partenariat
entre mobilize et 50 ans en Yvelines
ont commencé à travailler sur les
données liées à plusieurs sujets
concernant les routes et la circulation
sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et pour
mobilai c'est une expérimentation d'une
offre de avec data destiné aux
collectivités en collecte toutes les
données des véhicules connectés du
groupe Renault ces données là on les a
dans les miss on les a créé on apporte
de l'intelligence et on en extrait des
cas d'usage qui correspondent en fait
aux besoins de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
et Saint-Quentin Yvelines va devenir la
vitrine des 5 projets innovants de
mobylice alors voilà 5 projets innovants
je vais vous les donner donc ces données
sont collectées pour
déterminer la qualité des routes la
sécurité routière pour identifier les
zones accidentogènes les points de
chargement pour les véhicules
électriques les flux de circulation et
la pollution de l'air ou encore les
nuisances sonores tous ces sujets
intéressants les services de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines pour améliorer
les infrastructures du territoire on
écoute tout de suite Bertrand en cocard
il est vice-président en charge de la
Smart City à 50 ans en Yvelines si on
prend aujourd'hui l'état de nos
chaussées c'est vrai qu'on doit faire en
sorte que nos habitants ils le font
remontent nos informations il y a des
plateformes que nous avons
mais on a aussi des services qui vont
aller sur les routes pour constater
l'état de la route dont tout vous avez
des voitures qui circulent et remontent
ces informations là en temps réel 7
jours sur 7 24 heures sur 24 forcément
on est plus efficace et avec un meilleur
service public voilà vous l'avez compris
mobile eyes va aider 50 ans en Yvelines
à faire un diagnostic des routes et de
la circulation pour ensuite peut-être
prendre des décisions et alors pour
rassurer tous nos téléspectateurs
notamment les personnes qui circulent à
50 ans en Yvelines et qui possèdent un
véhicule Renault connecté les données
sont collectées de manière anonyme et si
vous avez donné bien évidemment l'accord
et c'est travaux en fait devrait aboutir
et livrer ses résultats d'ici la fin du
semestre et bien merci beaucoup Nicolas
dandry pour toutes ces précisions